it looks like a lunar landscape Demetri
Leon Chuck has come here to survey the
damage he's an environmental activist
and belongs to the pro-european out of
Maidan movement these craters are the
result of Amber mining the company
responsible was supposed to have
reforest at the land but that clearly
hasn't happened instead new craters have
been formed probably glam but diggers
who took advantage of the opportunity or
brass the police who guard the area the
activist meets a group of men nearby in
the village of class of in northwestern
Ukraine eventually they agree to show
him the fruits of their mining
activities possesion of illegally mined
amber can lead to prosecution in Ukraine
the small heap of stones could fetch one
thousand US dollars on the black market
the men say the gem stone is especially
sought-after by Chinese buyers the
illegal mining has been a financial boon
for the village where the money's been
used to build houses the men responsible
say they're doing the local area a favor
they've been able to build a playground
and there are plans to improve the roads
too
vassula maintains the government is
aware of and even cashes in on illegal
mining mining is good business for the
guys at the top too the bureaucrats
don't have to invest anything and still
in the federales he's refering to bribes
the miners say police officers and
security officials turn a blind eye to
the illegal activities in exchange for
cash payments
dimitr Leon Chuck wants to change that
he says huge areas are being destroyed
by illegal mining talking about
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
of people who are mining amber in the
forest
it's totally chaotic there's no system
in place there's evidence to back up the
claim this aerial footage shot by the
group of activists gives an indication
of the extent of the damage the illegal
miners are using pumps to wash the amber
toward the surface they plumb to a depth
of 20 meters the fracking is a huge
earner Demetri Leon Chuck and the other
activists managed to film the illegal
mining with their cell phones the
footage shows miners almost resembling
worker ants laboring hard it said that
installing a pump costs around six
hundred dollars in bribes that ensures
the authorities turn a blind eye
because my elbows are Kapali this is
what the landscape looks like after the
illegal miners have left the areas
around the mine have become barren
destroyed Demetri Leon chuck has
proposed an alternative could be
legalized we could organize it in such a
way that everyone can profit corporative
with ten to fifteen residents would have
enough work for two to three years after
this mind the area this should then have
to refill the holes plant trees and
reforest the area sales of the final
product fetch billions on the global
market especially in Europe and China
Demetri Leon Chuck can understand why
the many impoverished people from this
region feel entitled to a piece of the
pie he envisions a new system one in
which the environment is respected and
money generated from amber mining would
remain in the area and not end up in the
hands of corrupt officials